mais le météore voit où nous sommes
définir il a ensuite dit ici il s'agit
le smart se prépare je vous conseille
consommation médicale de la leçon de la
amélioré est le q
Eh bien, oui, je pense que j'ai, je suis
faire du cinéma de 18 ans et si je
Quito et en France ça a été un long chemin
[Musique]
moment
ça vaut le coup de tous les voir
planches
- eh bien c'est ce que je vois dans le
journaux et magazines et sont
éclairés et compagnons mais je pense que
Toutes les Espagnes sont toujours excellentes
inconnu de nous
Je pense que c'est un terme qui a été
nourri les journalistes
personne en espagne ne se reconnaît avec eriksson
Je suppose que tu veux dire qu'il y a un
beaucoup de choses ont changé
notre pays
ce qui est apparu beaucoup de
artistes
qui se comportent, parlent et agissent dans un
façon très différente des années 70
pour la mobilité actuellement
les artistes qui avaient du talent continuent
fonctionne même si la scène n'existe plus
de hasch avec nous
europe et amérique
[Musique]
réfléchit un peu et aussi que comme
comme l'Espagne est toujours allée dans l'autre sens
depuis l'an 69
A l'heure où toute l'Europe est
devenir très conservateur
L'Espagne se révèle être un pays très libre
Par exemple, en France
affiche de film interdite
parce qu'il y avait deux garçons qui couchaient ensemble
Eh bien, c'est l'histoire de deux frères qui
partager un secret de famille
à propos de la famille ne partagez pas aussi
le même petit ami
quoi d'autre partagent-ils
il y a un petit problème entre eux
parce que la fille est le nouveau problème
nous pouvons que la science qui était avant
j'étais un garçon
et il a changé le sexe du paradigme avec son
père
sexuellement
malgré sa grande spontanéité
tout à fait normal
mais devant
mais tu sais qu'à l'intérieur ils sont très
discrets ne sont pas aussi grotesques que les
bateaux
comme sujet de plaisir
quand ils ont commencé à régner en espagne
personne n'en voulait
mais néanmoins avec toutes ces années
se sont avérés être les mêmes
ont montré qu'il est difficile de
expliquer a montré qu'ils n'étaient pas les
héritiers de franc
malgré le fait que Juan Carlos
de belles peintures symboles qui
les filles aiment beaucoup et puis
vivre de nombreuses aventures et nettoyer
appel de l'option de recherche
et coureur de jupons
[Musique]